you know when you look at this one of
the real problems is the weakness of the
institutions on the right and the the
you know we'll call it the Republican
party in general but it's really sort of
the Old Guard Republicans because they
can't say they weren't warned they had
people warning them this was going to
happen and they didn't even try to fight
it they didn't even try to stop it they
didn't try to put up some independent
and fund them really well in these race
they didn't try anything to try to stop
these Soros DA's they just sort of
thought hey they sound crazy they're
saying crazy stuff that helps us because
we can cut adds to them saying crazy
stuff and the truth is no we're not
living in that world anymore guys you
let Communists into power and you let
them destroy a country we're not talking
about the ads for your next cycle
because they said some crazy thing